se nos pide simplificar la expresión 8 +
paréntesis 5 paréntesis 4 menos
paréntesis 6 + 10 entre 244 siempre que
veas una expresión como ésta donde haya
paréntesis división suma y resta
etcétera no querrás olvidar el orden de
las operaciones y déjame escribirlo por
aquí
paréntesis
en tesis
la mayor prioridad la tiene el
paréntesis que son estas curvas que
encierran a los números
estos son los paréntesis y reciben la
mayor prioridad
después de estos vienen los exponentes
estos tienen menor prioridad que los
paréntesis pero mayor prioridad sobre
otras operaciones pasando aquí export
en esta expresión no hay exponentes pero
los escribimos para futuras referencias
una forma en la que me gusta pensar es
que aunque el paréntesis reciba la mayor
prioridad después de éste los operadores
siguientes están ordenados de forma
descendente o ascendente mejor dicho
descendente de acuerdo a qué tan rápido
hacen crecer el valor de la expresión
cuando elevó algo a una potencia crece
muy rápido luego crece menos rápido
cuando multiplicamos o dividimos
por algo
qué es lo que viene después la
multiplicación y la división y al final
de todos está la suma y la resta
entonces estas son como las operaciones
más lentas
luego la multiplicación y división son
rápidas en cuanto a que hacen crecer o
odeco en cogerla el valor de la
expresión como ya habíamos mencionado y
los exponentes son las más rápidas
por último el paréntesis sin importar
nada tiene la mayor vivida entonces
déjame reescribir la expresión
8 más
por 4 menos
+ 10
entre 2
+ 44
según el orden de las operaciones el
paréntesis va primero entonces vamos a
resolver primero lo que está dentro de
los paréntesis y dos en este caso
tenemos estos paréntesis
tenemos entre paréntesis el 5 en
realidad lo que está dentro del
paréntesis ya está resuelto ya tiene un
valor igual acá ya no tenemos que hacer
ninguna operación ya está el 4 sin
embargo vamos a operar el 5 por 4 5 por
4 es igual a 20
y luego lo que está
en este paréntesis de aquí vamos a
escribir lo que está en este paréntesis
pudiera parecer natural que ya lo que
está dentro del paréntesis lo resolvamos
de izquierda a derecha sin embargo
dentro del mismo paréntesis una
expresión se resuelve respetando el
orden de las operaciones no se olviden
el orden de las operaciones por lo que
vamos a utilizar por aquí otro
paréntesis para
resaltar que lo que va primero es la
división la división tiene mayor
prioridad que la suma por lo tanto vamos
a poner esto en un paréntesis y vamos a
resolver 10 entre 2 es igual a
y eso todavía tenemos que operarlo con 6
sumarlo con 6 vamos a pasar lo que falta
acá abajo
después todavía nos falta resolver lo
que está dentro de este paréntesis 65 es
igual a 11
vamos a bajar los demás
820 entonces queda 8 20 menos 11 más 44
ahora si nos podemos fijar aquí tenemos
operadores que están en el mismo nivel
del orden de las operaciones recuerda
que cuando tenemos operadores al mismo
nivel el orden que debemos seguir es
ahora si de izquierda a derecha por lo
que vamos a realizar primero
esta operación 820 es igual a 28 menos
otra vez respetando el orden de
izquierda a derecha vamos a realizar
esta operación 28 menos 11 es igual a 17
más 44
y por último la suma de 10 6 17 44 que
es 17 10 + 44 54 más 7 son 61
y terminamos